terrible alors la main qu est-ce que en
vous voyant être devenu le chantre du
capital est ce que vous croyez pas que
votre père vous savez c'est un ancien
communiste
ils ont fait aussi beaucoup de chemin
alors j'ai poursuivi le chemin qu'il
avait entamée si je puis dire on était
allé très loin parce que quand même lui
peut être communiste et avoir été déçu
par par le stalinisme il peut avoir été
déjà par par budapest il peut avoir été
déçu par beaucoup de choses comme ça
mais malgré tout il est comme il a un
idéal au départ qui est l'idéal
communiste le fait que son fils soit
devenu le chantre du nouveau capitalisme
salon et je peux dormir mais vous voyez
qu'en dit libéral de gauche c'est assez
utile parce que j'espère que lui
comprend gauche et que les gens avec
lesquels je travaille comprennent
libéral ouais très bien on rallume